hello and welcome to the EGU so is the
lunchtime of the Monday what's just
happened is I've been in talks all
morning from 8:30 to 10:30 that was on
pattern formation in geosciences so from
emergence to dynamics itself and then
from 10:30 to 12:00 it was on time
series analysis and that covered pretty
much everything and the way that it
works is that you can pretty much go
into whatever session you want
I'm not even obliged to stay for the
whole session I can just walk around and
do whatever and the several things that
every time that I do I would like to do
either in future I might not stick
around for all the sessions because you
can read all the abstracts as an app
which you can download for footing as
well as a paper one and you can read all
the abstracts on that and you can see
what's going to be relevant to your
interests and there was some which
definitely one relevance month were
still interesting apologies that there's
not gonna be much footage of the talks
themselves you need permission from the
speaker cont rightly if you want to get
footage either photos or video and
because I'm socially awkward I'm not
going to get it because I'm not going to
ask for it right now it's lunchtime so
between depending on the group between
12:00 and 1:30 or 1213 1:30 you've got
lunch there's several places you can eat
here hopefully this afternoon which is
dynamical meter which is gonna be more
relevant but yeah I will transform
someone's after me
so this is the evening after day one
this is Monday at Lee's you talk to you
at lunchtime what's happened since then
we got lunch with cutlery which makes a
nice change after the bark off yesterday
first thing this afternoon we went to
the face of the earth talk about rocks
so much different perfection and long
which today with the talk every day
today's talk was rocks and it was all
about tectonic motion and dynamically
modeling the formation of mountain
ranges and that kind of stuff and there
are five different points across the
conference where there are these face of
the earth sensors so there's one its
atmosphere rock water life space yeah
and we had looked very atmosphere one
when literally in a cloud there are like
three different sections we walking into
this like especially constructive thing
and then like you in the side a cloud
there's like a cumulus one is like a
which is you know just like a generic
fluffy cloud then there's like a
thundercloud and then there's we think
it's a rain forest kind of one because I
really feel it yeah kima the Nimbus kind
of thing which is really awesome and
then there's one of those for everyone I
don't think they're all quite as
immersive as that at least I hope the
space one isn't let's put all that back
and then this afternoon we met up with
some colleagues that we knew from a
statistic seminar a statistics workshop
which was done at xte and also some
people I knew from Oxford and we met
with them the Pico standard which is for
help me out at all
and the way that it works is that these
people will do a two-minute talk each
and they'll be like 10 or so talks and
they have two minutes to sort of
summarize their research and then you're
directed to these screens which are like
widescreen TVs which are interactive so
you go up and they're like PowerPoint
presentations that you can click on
figures and they'll come out with more
information and you can flip through
slides and there's a whole range of
information and then we went into this
dynamic meteorology session which was so
packed we walked in and there were like
10 people waiting in the door and then
by the end of it there were just people
queuing like you know just sitting in
the gangway yeah all these got all of
the talks have take place in two rooms
there are like 10 things going on at
once
probably more than 10 say we were put in
quite a small one and it was not big
enough and the other thing which we both
were so we went down for meteorology
both me and Tom Tom and I even and then
we went off to the geo cinema so there's
a cinema I say cinema it's like a room
with a projector that's been running all
conference and it's a series of films
about the earth and about earth science
which have been put on and we watched it
was about an hour and a half about
climate change and a journalist sort of
trying to understand climate change from
a physical perspective and what a
changing climate will mean and that's
been that was really cool actually that
was that was surprisingly well named so
there's this workshop tomorrow about
filmmaking which I'm really interested
in going to so that'll be cool but we're
all men so they're gonna go to bed even
though it's like 8:00 it's nice okay
that's a lot better okay we'll see you
tomorrow
hey guys so this is the morning of the
Tuesday I am again in one of the quiet
that's the conference center so I can
talk to you
I literally just Skyped my girlfriend
because there's of Wi-Fi everywhere here
unfortunately this morning the session
which I was gonna be going to on
atmospheric convection was so busy it
was in another reasonable room that they
were at space i reconned me and Tom
walked in and there was it was only
standing room in fact there wasn't even
really standing and we were just started
to stood in the door so I kind of had to
leave that and I just did a bunch of
emails and some Scouter and then now
hopefully I'm gonna be going to a
session on Cassini which is a mission
that has been orbiting Saturn it's not
my field of research tool but I used to
want to work in space
so I'm really hoping I get to get to see
that
so I just had the Cassini session which
was incredible and I don't really know
that much about the mission but I've
managed to pick up a few things the fact
that they're proposing to float a
spacecraft between the gaps in silence
reigns as competition just as an idea
that some doesn't same where I am now is
because that session finished a lil bit
early I'm honestly as opposed to so
everything you know the standard way
that you do researchers you publish a
paper but when you want to get people to
read it more personally you do either a
talk at a conference poster each one of
these posters represents people's were
pretty much every one of these posters
represents a paper either that has been
published along ecology and there are
about 15,000 is is an extraordinary
amount of research that's being trying
to get more and behind me it's frankly
amazing amount of science that's because
all of Europe's and Geosciences
you know nuclear science just shows how
much is going up next we're going off to
lunch then this afternoon we've got
picot session
we've got something on atmospheric
turbulence scientists must film the
evening in this oh yeah and in this
keynote lecture which today is on the
water so that's really quite fun because
I know very little about hydrology
something I've noticed by the way which
I wasn't expecting is that these kind of
conferences it reminds me of kids when
they all have to do a presentation in
class because when I was in the Cassini
talk everybody in the audience pretty
much was on a laptop finalizing their
presentation and even if it wasn't
necessary for that that talk itself they
were just sound the audience getting
ready for their own talk and everybody
just want my woman goes up and does that
thing and some people clearly humpin and
it works sometimes you see groups of
people together sometimes you see guys
who frantically putting together at all
it just shows that scientists a kind of
kids really you know people though
people grow up in some ways but in other
words I think we stay the same which is
kind of affirming people all just
actually can be kind of movies
so I just got recognized by a subscriber
which is really Rick Murray oh I think
they say your last name very nice to
meet you I'm just doing this between the
afternoon session on exoplanets and to
make you feel so fine so this is the
evening of Tuesday we have come back in
the hotel after dinner after our
filmmaking workshop which wasn't really
workshop it was more of a talk really it
was to giving my two Dutch guys Dan
bring Chris and Martin ruse the latter
of which used to be a planetary
scientist and now has made more films
than the scientific publications but it
was it was really interesting there's a
huge workshop there must have been about
hundred people that start with although
people were leaving messes so it went on
which covered all kinds of filmmaking
things like from the this type of camera
and microphone to mostly talking about
the message and the idea of producing
video rather than just rushing in
blindly which was which was really
useful although I did find out tonight
that I get more views per month for NASA
NASA salary channel does which is kind
of cool
tomorrow we've actually got the morning
off so I'm gonna go and get some
postcards and I need to find a tea
mozart teddy for someone I'm gonna say
who and then in the afternoon it's the
biggest stratosphere troposphere
coupling session which is really why
we're here and we know some of the
people presenting so we are going to
depending on whether we like them or not
ask them very snarky questions there is
one guy we don't know who he's called
what's up why he's cooked we don't know
who he is who we went to see who is
dynamic meteorology was in another song
he's been in a few and here he made a
girl cry he outright made a girl cry
that he asked the questions he was
asking about she presented a talk
basically saying in other words isn't
your research a bit useless he seems to
be MIT notorious people seem to know
about him and he has a record
so you know tomorrow tomorrow afternoon
is the big session for we're really here
and specifically the strap drop coupling
and looking at model results one of some
of the people we know and met in
previous events is the two people who
actually giving contradictory talks one
after the other so that should be fun
though posters loads of posters
happening tonight although I miss my
free beer again so nice I'm definitely
definitely definitely getting at least
one tomorrow Tom doesn't drink so I can
like yours yeah that's that's great
talking up - I've been working my way
through Austrian beer and food has been
here we both like käsespätzle castor
splats which is kind of like an Austrian
macaroni cheese and I also had Oh garlic
on when it was cool now it was like
stewed plums and pancake basically at
various beers so that's gonna be added
to tomorrow night so I guess we'll see
you tomorrow morning